what are the first things an actor has
to do once they get to
La I realize that you're going to be
rejected a lot and that it will take
longer than you ever thought um I came
with a two-year plan and I thought that
was uh giving myself a lot of extra time
but I've been here four full years this
is going into my fifth year and um only
in the last year did I start to have any
type of decent success and by that I
mean that I could keep food on the table
regularly but but I came
I I think that if you come you have to
decide am I going to cut all ties with
other careers and do this or not and I
chose to not have a day job and um it's
made it more difficult but I couldn't
have reached any success without it when
you came here four years ago how many
IMDb credits did you have two and how
many do you have now uh 100 I just
passed my 100th IMBD credit and still
nobody knows who the hell I am so you
can make a lot of movies without
actually bursting into the the big
public Consciousness I think that's
another thing actors need to understand
you know so I've done a couple of TV
movies for Hallmark Channel and they're
great and I'm glad to be in them and
they're yes they help but they do not
change your life and they don't change
your career there's so much noise that
an actor has to burst through that you
have to understand even if you get a big
project it may be a bump but it's
probably going to be a slight bump it's
more the accumulation of IMBD credits
that make a difference what about
getting acclimated to La you came from
some somewhere else I did and how does
one get acclimated to LA and also
acclimated to actors hours whatever that
is well I came from the East Coast I've
done theater New York and up and down
the East Coast for 14 years and I came
out here expecting it to be much the
same and it's not La is not really a
city that's one thing you have to
understand if you come here it's a
collection of smaller cities geography
is very difficult and um your
friendships um your ability to do
auditions and work is all determined by
traffic and and that's a huge thing to
realize when you come here um if you're
going to come to LA and try to be an
actor you have to be completely
available emotionally spiritually
physically um your relationships
whatever they are have to understand
that this is your priority Michael Kane
said and I think he's right he said this
cannot be if you want to make it this
cannot be just a full-time job it has to
be a full-time
Obsession um and I find that to be very
true you have to be completely obsessed
to the point that people who are not in
the business will
say you're crazy if they don't say that
you're probably not obsessed enough to
make it in the
business what about looking for that
side job while you're looking for those
acting roles that are going to put food
on the table where would you look for
these side jobs and what type of hours
would you look for in terms of those
jobs if you think you have to have a
side job uh when you first come to La
try to get one that's very very flexible
A lot of people are bartenders um
Caterers anything that's uh
parttime um don't get something that's
going to lock you into particular hours
every week because invariably you'll
miss an audition and that's not going to
do anything you might not have gotten
the audition but it kills your morale so
I came here with a no day job plan and
uh it's been tough you know there''s
been a lot of peanut butter years it's
good that I'm thin if you that's another
thing if you're going to come to La you
should probably decide that you're not
going to eat as much as you thought you
might eat or you're accustomed to eating
in the first few years you'll have times
when you eat nothing but noodles and
peanut butter that's just the nature of
the business other times you'll have
steak uh but yeah your day job should be
flexible and what do you wish someone
had told you before you got to LA or
were you glad no one did say anything I
wish that before I came that someone had
said don't come because this is very
very difficult it's a a cruel town and a
cruel business no one cares and you have
to do it yourself now I still would have
come but I would have come with more
awareness of just how difficult this
business is all that people ever see
about Hollywood is the gloss and um the
entertainment and the glamour that's all
produced for the general public not for
actors I wish that someone would produce
content for actors saying do not move to
Los Ang Angel it is very very difficult
and then the only people who will do it
are those who'll Say by damn I'm going
to do it I can take it because that's
the kind of spirit you have to have you
have to be tenacious and you can never
ever give up or you will not make it I
think one thing that's interesting is
when people don't have somewhere to go
back to they tend to stick it out what
would you tell someone on how to
emotionally survive coming here because
it is it's very cold and I think people
need an outlet whether it's whether it's
hiking their Church whatever it is I
hike in Griffith Park uh I come to this
place every Sunday
morning and spend time here and this is
my Solace I think you have to have
something outside of yourself be a
relationship with God a higher power um
your relationships with your family um
you have to have other outlets other
than acting because that's what allows
you to you know to put your passion into
your acting at the same time I know
people who never think about acting
except when they have an audition and I
think that's a big mistake um you're a
small business person and you have to
think of yourself as a small business
person so when I get up in the morning
I'm going to work when I put my feet on
the floor I'm at work because I am my
business so there's not a moment that
goes by even if I'm hiking even if I'm
reading I'm always looking for things
that I can apply to my business I think
that's the only way you make it we're
entrepreneurs and that's another thing
that people don't say to actors they say
come here and explore your inner self
and and and feel the the character well
yeah that's great but first you have to
get on set and you don't do that unless
you're a good business person I don't
mean to sound so Earnest this is what La
has done to me this is what La will do
to an actor if you achieve any type of
success here you become a bit more
serious and then people say boy oh
you're kind of a hard ass but it's a
tough
town you made a living as an actor
outside of La for a good 12 years
correct so for the last several years
now you've made a living from acting in
La what's your opinion on where an
unestablished actor should live if he or
she wants to make a living as an actor
if you want to make a living as an actor
live centrally um Hollywood is great
because it's easy to get you everywhere
um Studio City also okay but look at the
map and try to put right in the center
and don't be as concerned with going to
the beach or where the clubs are I mean
maybe this is easier for me to say
because I'm in the middle age but I'm
not here to play I'm here to work so
where I chose to live was determined by
talking to people in the business and
asking them where am I most likely to
have to drive to and I want to be right
in the center of that for God's sake
don't get far out on the freeway um and
think I'm going to drive into La for
every audition and shoot because you're
not you're going to get a call back that
says hey can you be here in two hours
and you look at traffic and you're like
no I can't so you have to plan for that
it's a it's a full-time job every single
day it's a full-time job speaking of
clubs and having fun I know that
networking is a great part of the
business and a lot of it's who you know
but what about people that want to be
part of the group and they're always
hanging out and they want to talk about
films but maybe nothing gets done and
they don't want to rock the group
dynamics do you think you have to almost
be a lone wolf in some sense I do think
you have to be a lone wolf because
you're moving within several groups of
people I have small Independent
Producers now I have some larger
producers that I deal with I have
directors that I work for for 50 bucks
when I first came here I have larger
directors now who are doing million
dooll films and and all of these circles
rarely intersect and you have to be able
to to go and speak to each one of them
as needed
um I I don't think it's a good idea to
hang with a certain group all the time
um you do have to be social you do have
to be able to network but I do believe
that being a lone wolf is an advantage
to an actor because you are like a wolf
right I mean you're always you're always
always on the prow you're always on the
hunt you're always looking for the
relationship that will help you and I
know that sounds cynical but that's the
business and that's any business you
spend your time on the relationships
that are likely to benefit you and that
person it's
symbiotic well you see it you go into a
restaurant everyone turns around to see
who's walking in yes and then they look
do I know that person can I go up to
their table can I pitch them something
so I think everybody does it on any
level whether they're starting starting
out or whether they're an established
Studio person I think you're always
looking for that next thing but no one
can hook you up and this is something
people should tell actors who are come
into LA because I've now just started to
reach the level where I will have a
younger actor occasionally say Hey you
know could you hook me up with so and so
no no I can't it took me four years to
hook myself up baby you know you hook
yourself up was the great old story of
uh Betty Davis and I don't know where
she was but uh some young actress asked
her you know how would you advise me to
get into Studio films in Hollywood and
she said take Fountain Avenue it's
quicker than
Hollywood and that's her advice and she
was saying I got mine you get yours yes
you'll help other people out but no one
can I don't think even a really really
established actor can call a director
and say hey I think you should put bill
on my film because I like him people
don't like that they don't like being
forced why do you think a lot of people
realize that because I've heard from
people that I know that they thought
friends or someone would help them get
that extra leg up up and they were
disappointed once it didn't happen oh
yes I do think a lot of people and I
think it's a big lie and people who come
here need to know I just spoke to
someone yesterday he was like oh I got a
buddy he's on a TV show he's going to
let me sleep on his couch and he said
he'd hook me up I got that message on
Facebook and I wrote back good luck man
I hope everything works out but I'm
thinking he ain't going to hook you up
you can't hook anybody up here it's
every person for themself it's a very
mercenary bit do I sound cold no no I
think you sound like a real
this is business this is not play this
is not glamour you put on the makeup you
put on the dress you put on the suit you
go do the red carpet but you do it
because it's a part of business the
ordinary public for whom this video is
not intended does not need to know any
of this it spoils their illusion just as
much as if the camera tilted up on a set
and suddenly you could see the ceiling
this is not for them but if you're an
actor and you're moving to
La this is for you this is a very very
difficult business it's a of a
business and it'll eat you
alive and you talked about earlier
coming to La a little bit older
sometimes people come out of college or
maybe they skip college and they come
here and and do you think maybe that was
even more helpful that you came as a
more mature person because you weren't
swayed by hanging out with the group and
wanting to be with the cool crowd having
drinks on a Friday night that was weird
even when I was 20 um so I probably
would have been alone there but yeah um
it's been good because you know I was a
theater guy for 14 years and I did a lot
of traveling on back roads and loading
in loading out and cleaning bathrooms
and putting on Mark Twain wigs and
basements that only had cold water and
scrubbing it off and you know you you
learn doing that it gives you confidence
I think by the time you reach middle age
you do have confidence that that it's
going to be all right you know that you
can do pretty much anything or try
anything the bad side of coming in
middle age of course is that it's a very
youth-based culture and you have to find
a niche which is why I've you know been
lucky to have this face and be able to
be the scary guy the disturbing guy the
weird guy because otherwise I'd just be
a middle-age actor with bad skin and I'd
have been back east in six months if I
wasn't
frightening Bill what would you say to
an actor that's in the wonderful
position of being offered paying roles
but then there's that catch there's that
sort of problem with prosperity where
all those people that knew you as the
great actor that could do things for
free for the love of it now know that
you're working actor and there's a
cost this is probably the most difficult
uh transition that I've had to go
through in the past year you do work for
free when you come here and because you
just want to rack up IMBD credits you
work for very low pay you take as many
jobs as you can get but if you stay here
long enough and you're able to survive
you will reach a point where you have to
surrender some of that control to your
representation and you have to trust
your representation enough so that they
say you're not going to be in this
project you say no to the project you
become an offer actor I have less
auditions now um it it it it doesn't
mean that I don't have to try it just
means that now my roles come more
through
relationships than through cold
auditions than they used to um because
people have somewhat of an awareness of
who you are but it's very difficult when
someone comes to you who you've had a
prior relationship with at a very very
low rate and they come to you with a
project and you have to say please speak
to my representation you know I'm glad
that we're friends and I love working
with you but talk to my representation
that's a big step especially if you've
come here as a
do-it-yourselfer and you've worked very
hard to get to that level and then they
speak to your representation and they
may call you and say Karen I can't
believe that I'm being talked to this
way I've heard that and what they mean
by I can't believe I'm being talked to
this way is I can't believe that your
representation is asking for a fair rate
of
pay um and they'll say things like well
it's coming out of pocket well
everything comes out of pocket you know
nonprofit this is business and this is
what I do for a living and at some point
and this is the hardest thing for an
actor to do cuz we're all needy we're
all needy is to say I have a a a skill
have a certain set of skills that I can
do on camera I have something I can
bring to your production and I want to
bring it to your production but you have
to pay me to do it just as people have
to pay you to do your job you don't ask
a plumber to work for free and I know
that actors have to work for free but as
soon as you can stop doing that stop
because it's a bad habit and it's not
going to bode well for your future and
your representation won't like it and
when you reach a certain point you
depend on that
representation well what if someone says
to you oh this is a passion project
we're all here out of the love of it and
and we're a nonprofit and everyone else
is doing it for free and if everyone
else is doing it for free then everyone
else must be rich and I'm
not you know I don't have stakes in the
freezer um this is a business there is
room for passion but at some point the
movie is going to be released let's say
I want to hire you and it comes down to
an additional hundred bucks silly
example but it comes down to 100 and you
want that 100 bucks and I'm saying no so
I got to stop and think is Karen going
to bring an additional hundred bucks
value to my project that's 10 DVD sales
is it likely that in the world 10 human
beings will buy my movie more because
Karen's in it if not you don't need to
be in it but the answer is probably yes
if I approached you in the first place
so both sides on the negotiating table
have to be smart you can't insult the
other
person but this is a business and actors
do this for a living it's my passion but
it's also my living I'm a stock and if a
stock gets to a certain point there's no
shareholder that wants to say well let's
lower the value because then you'll
never get back to the value that you
were I know it sounds cold and hard and
even
passionless but if the deal is worked I
actually get on set I pour my passion
into it but my passion is not for
working for free that's not the way to
build a career do you think people
realize that when you approach someone
for pay and then you try to kind of
retract and say hey is there any way we
could do sort of a barter type of a
thing that that sour it even more I
think so yeah it's just a matter of
respect I've had actors say offer me gas
money at least that at least that it's
just showing
respect to the actor um yeah I think so
and and you look at the level that the
actor's at too what project said they
worked on recently do they actually
bring value to their project if they
don't fine work for free or don't be in
my movie but if you have actually
approached an actor and made an offer
and then their representation comes back
to you and says that's not enough what
can you do don't be pissy about it
negotiate it's like any other business
I'm buying a car I'm not going to pay
the sticker price but you're not going
to let me walk off the lot for two grand
either we're going to go back and forth
back and forth back and forth and and I
have noticed that what seems to be
different in this business at least on
an independent film level is some people
don't want to do the back and forth they
don't like the process of negotiation
because they just want to make the
passion project and so do I but you
never get to that unless you can
negotiate again it's looking at it as a
business so friendships let's say they
then come back to you and say I can't
believe your representation spoke to me
like that and people do how do you
handle that without hurting their
feelings and losing the Friendship do I
owe them a favor or not because if I owe
them a favor then I'm going to call my
representation and say you know I need
to repay this favor can can we work it
out to do this project but if I don't
owe them a favor and they call me and
say your representation has hurt my
feelings and I'll say my representation
is not me and you're not hiring me your
friend you're hiring ing Bill Jr who is
a commodity that I've spent four years
busting my ass to build up and that's
what that commodity that's what the
current market value of that commodity
is I'm still Billy I'm still your friend
but it's hard to make that separation
sometimes Bill we want to congratulate
you I understand that you just signed
with a talent agency
and I think the last time we spoke to
you was almost a year ago so A lot's
been happening I think you we've had
numerous things happen um can you tell
us how you signed with them and what
lessons did you learn in the process
that you can share with other actors
that's a very good question um I've been
trying to get signed
with a higher level uh agency or an
agent at all since I got here my manager
did this I have a wonderful manager
named Matt Chason and he made these
contacts uh but I had to accumulate
enough of a body of work for the agency
to be interested in me then it took a
couple of months to set up the meeting
and then when we actually did go and
meet it was very very different than
agent meetings I've been in before
because at that level things are quite
serious um there's very little joviality
and there shouldn't be because it's a
big decision for both parties um so and
it's been it's been good and it's been
different because
now I'm represented by someone who has
some standing in the industry so when
people come for projects that's who they
go to and and um my manager and my agent
have become sort of a buffer which is
hard in one way you know it's hard
because it is about
relationships um but if you think of
yourself as a product then you know
there's always the middleman and those
who are representing the product and
putting it on the shelf and that's
that's that's the best way to think of
it what can you tell some other actors
about the process and what some of the
steps you took also too from maybe prior
people that wanted to sign you and you
pulled back say no uh be willing to say
no because someone wants to sign you
doesn't mean that you should sign with
them um because once you reach a level
of doing 50 IMBD projects there are
people who say sure I'll take you on um
but I've really depended on my manager
to say let's wait let's wait let's wait
until we can get with an agency that
means something and that's hard to do
it's really hard to wait because again
actors are need
we just want to work we just want to
work we just want to work and that's all
that matters to us but from a business
standpoint um there's more and it's the
power of saying no and it's it's the
hardest thing in the world for an actor
to say no how can we
practice how do we practice saying no
what if we're people Pleasers and we
don't we just don't want to hurt I am a
people pleaser I want everyone to like
me to the point that I have Google Alert
set up and if someone on a blog or
review says something about me or a
performance that is not favorable I'll
go there I'll leave a comment and say
you were absolutely right I agree with
you I made bad mistakes there and um you
know I hope you'll give me another
chance in an effort to get that person
which they usually do to then say oh
well you know for sure I'm glad you
thanks for writing and I'll be looking
for you in the future like it's
pathological with actors that we have to
have everybody has to like us and our
relationship with everybody has to be
okay I don't know any actor who likes to
have someone they think does not like
them I have one wardrobe person in the
100 projects I've done who doesn't like
me I hung the hanger the wrong way and
it was early on and I didn't know the
way to hang the hanger but I was trying
to be nice and instead I made extra work
for her and I'm still looking for a
chance to work with her again to make
her like me is that
sick
so what's a soft no and what's a hard no
cuz some people are really good at hard
Nos and they enjoy being the contrarian
and they enjoy being the one in control
but how do you do a soft no oh you
better do soft nose in LA or you ain't
going to work if all you can do is hard
NOS forget it because you insult people
um a hard no is Karen you're crazy why
would I work on your project I will
never ever work with you or anybody that
you know again because I've said that
and how many people will you tell that
but a soft know is I really really love
this project and I love the role and I
want to do it and I wish that I were
financially stable enough to be able to
pick and choose my roles because if I
did I'd be on your set
today I'm just not able to do it right
now and I feel really bad about it and
I'm embarrassed to even mention it to
you but I hope you might find in your
heart to forgive me for not being able
to work with you that's an extreme soft
no that was beautiful but I mean it I
always mean it you know you never tell
somebody no you always say oh my gosh
you know I'm so sorry I wish I really
wish I could and I want to but I just
can't right now but in the future I
really want to work with you because and
this this is another thing actors come
into La need to realize people love to
be stroked they love to be
stroked look up the IMBD what have they
done research them on the web I really
want to work with you in future even
though I'm saying now because I like
what you did on
ABCD then you've built a relationship
within the
no that's the way to do it I like that
now your representation can give a hard
no and then you can say oh my gosh you
know what are you going to do I'm sorry
my manager my agent are such hard asses
but I really love you keep your personal
relationship good
is there anything in this business
that's
real hearing myself talk I'm
wondering is this entirely a business of
Illusion
possibly yeah yeah but I I think what
you're saying is is correct in terms of
like the the coldness and being able to
to even on that red carpet cuz that that
little part is just such a minuscule
part and that's what everybody sees and
and they don't see where where you walk
into rooms and you feel the vibe and
it's not as friendly or it's not you
know and it's not to be negative you
know we're trying to be more positive
with our film courage interviews but I I
think people from other parts don't
realize that it it is tough and and I
think it's good that you're giving a
healthy dose of reality and you're not
sugar coating coating it and you know
you know follow the your dreams the
money will follow you know that that
kind of thing I think the only reason to
do this is because you feel that you
were born to do it and so that's why you
put up with all the crap and that's why
you think through all the business
strategy and that's why you do it all is
because it feeds something inside of you
to pretend to be other people or to
create stories where other people
pretend to be other people I have no
idea where that comes from but I think
it's an inborn vocation that's the only
kind of person that should be an actor
and then your satisfaction is actually
getting to do what you love for a living
if you do all this other stuff so I
answer my own question by saying that's
what's real the passion that's within us
that that's what's real and you have to
keep that burning and keep it alive even
as you go through all of the business
and if you're able to sit in a cubicle 5
days a week and then just go to movies
and live all that out on the weekends
then it's great but don't come to
Hollywood bill I believe your idea about
acting is not just talent and creativity
and Imagination but it's also this
business side this very left brain type
of thinking about about marketing and
spending time on the computer and and
selling yourself and being your brand as
you've moved up the ranks as you've been
here four years and book more roles and
become more noticeable do you see that
other people in that Stratosphere also
think the same and the ones that maybe
you might have climbed past didn't think
that way well I don't think I might I
don't think I've climb past anybody
they're probably right on my butt right
now and I just don't know it but um but
the answer is yes um the the when you
deal with actors who have been here
longer than I have and have been more
successful than I have they're very very
business-minded and very marketing
minded and very strategic minded I don't
think they would have lasted es
especially not at my age you know when I
when I look at actors who are my age and
who most of them have either quit or
they've made it really big and so the
people that I know who are in my age
range who've made it really big have
done it by being absolutely strategic
when it comes to marketing I think it's
important I've done some marketing
seminars where I've spoken to actors and
said this is what you need to do and
then I've had some of them afterwards uh
contact me and say well can I pay you to
do
it no I mean I it's it's a full-time job
and you have to do it from your passion
nobody can do this for
you um but it's the thing actors don't
like to do paperwork and you know
generally we don't like that side of
things but
it's essential if you were to break down
your day or your week how much time of
your waking hours are spent on the
business side the being at the computer
and how much is spent on the creative oh
thinking of a Great Character back study
and and and rehearsing lines and hey can
we meet to go over this scene 12 hours
in 1 hour the one hour is a stretch um
I've got to shoot tomorrow so when I get
done with you guys I'm going to walk
around Hollywood and look at my lines
and feel them and struggle with them and
think oh my God I can't do this then
I'll walk up to Griffith Park and I'll
pray and I'll think I can't do this and
then I'll decide that I can do it and
then it's done I'm ready to go to set
but I've spent the entire week before
talking to you guys marketing and
submitting and stroking relationships
and looking for projects and reading
scripts so yeah a lot of it's business
reading scripts is hard when people
start sending you scripts you get five
scripts in a week
it's wonderful to be sent scripts but it
takes two hours to read each one if
you're actually going to read it and not
cheat and just say oh my role is Bob I'm
just going to look for all the instances
of Bob in the script uh so yes the
marketing the business that's
99.9% of the
time you mentioned walking around
Hollywood reciting your lines we just
saw a young man the other day and we
were so fascinated by this guy was in
his own world rehearsing is that
something that you do is that I I found
it fascinating to watch this yeah cuz
people think you're crazy and it helps
the sense of isolation that you have to
have as an actor um you have to be
completely in your character and I do
this you know I walk to the gym walk
back and forth with my lines my little
Sid in my head I'm talking to myself out
loud and people stare and pull their
children away and you know it's okay
that's that's what an actor does I find
that the best way for me to to learn
lines and to to get the meaning of the
lines is to move while I'm doing it I
can't do it while I'm sitting down so
it's good to walk walk and be in motion
and try to figure out these lines and
the words will tell you how they want to
be said if you walk with them enough
like you might think you have a line
reading but just keep working it keep
working it keep walking keep moving keep
moving and the words will tell you no
this is how I want to be said and and
then you'll have your reading that you
can take to set and have something else
in your pocket if they act want
something different and to reiterate
what you said that's like a 1 hour
possibly portion of your day or and the
other's 12 oh yeah if that yeah if that
because it it doesn't to sit around
thinking about how I might play a
character that I haven't
booked it's of no benefit I need to be
spending this time booking the character
then I can start working on the
character it's not a good business for
dreamers I guess unless you're extremely
young extremely beautiful and you have
kind of a backup of uh
money then you could sit around and
dream
but I can't I don't have time to dream I
don't have time to sit around with other
actors and have coffee and I don't have
time for any of that this is so
hard I I don't mean to sound Petty in
that way but you have to be completely
focused on what you're doing what about
to do a lot of scene study in films sit
around all day and watch movies that you
love and talk about how Nicholson played
it like this and it was amazing and look
how he got angry right here and what
about that I cannot bring myself when
I'm in my apartment to ever watch a
movie because I always think there's
something else I could be doing what
else could I be doing to further my
career instead of looking at Jack
Nicholson's
career but I will go two movies a couple
times a week the Egyptian runs a lot of
older films and I've really enjoyed that
I've enjoyed studying these older actors
who were in my sort of type like Lee
Marvin and watching Edward G Robinson
and watching how these old guys worked
the camera even though the acting styles
are different there's a lot to be
learned so I'll go to school there you
know about once a week but sitting
around watching movies in the apartment
I can't do it because I'm always looking
at the computer and thinking is there
one more thing I could do before I go to
bed tonight is there one more thing I
could do that might Advance my career I
am God I'm obsessed listening to myself
talk I want to quit this business I'm
too obsessed but I don't know how to do
anything else for a living this is all I
know how to do and all I want to do it's
kind of sad isn't it no I think it's
great bill it's day one of a new shoot
and it's an hour before you have to be
on set what are you doing rejoicing
because in a business with a 98%
unemployment rate I'm about to work and
this is the happiest time because then
you can leave behind all the marketing
all the business all the other stuff
we've discussed because none of it
really matters once you're on set then
you're an artist then your passion can
can flare um I go off the grid for
shoots now I started doing this after a
movie called Children of Sorrow it was
the first time I went off the grid and
the results were good and now cell phone
off computer off I don't talk if I'm on
set I'm on set I'm on set I'm on set
that's it that's the only answer can
give to any question the world just exp
I'm on set man I'm sorry I'll do within
a minute all right unless it's you know
you your kids in trouble or something
like that if unless it's an extreme
emergency away from the world and that
hour before you actually have to leave
the house to go there and leave early do
something that you love do something you
really really love what is it that you
love doing more than anything in the
world I like doing
push-ups I love it I really love the
feel of it and then I love the
and then trying to do some more so I
might spend the hour listening to music
I really like or doing push-ups you know
um do something you really really like
cuz when you get on set you don't want
to be technical minded or
business-minded you want to be in touch
with your passion and the reason that
you go to all this trouble to do it
let's take it a step further how about
um a few days before you're supposed to
be on set are there any things you're
doing differently yes um a few days
before you be on set every single day
your lines I'm a big believer and then I
got this from Michael Kane the best five
bucks I ever spent was Michael Kane's
book acting on
film um people should buy it he said
work your lines so completely that
anyone could throw you a Queue at any
point in the day and you hit them back
with the queue so that there's
absolutely no thought and I do this by
writing them out in long hand and then
seeing if I can write them
backwards and so every morning for a few
days before I'll go through this
exercise of writing out the lines and
then seeing if I can write them
backwards and then you truly do know I'm
frontwards and backwards uh and then all
throughout the day I'm thinking I'm
thinking I'm thinking I'm working I'm
working I'm working I'm working and you
a little bits of business start to come
to you that would not if you didn't have
those extra days to do it don't wait
till the day of Because by that time you
should already you know have some
choices prepared and if the director
wants something different you have maybe
something else in your pocket which film
set was your greatest
teacher there were two there were two
both were good and both really stretched
me one was a film called the retrieval
which is played it South by Southwest
it's a Civil War era drama I play a
bounty hunter in the 1860s and I'm after
Escape slaves the director wanted me to
be still in the frame and as you can see
by all this it's hard for me to be still
but there's a great power to being still
in the frame and he wanted me to be
still and he wanted me to drop my vocal
range and he wanted on almost no
inflection as I spoke to you that's what
he wanted that's what I had to learn to
do and it was really devilishly hard but
the results are quite good and the
reviews have been good and I learned
that Children of Sorrow was a a horror
film in which I play a cult leader in
the desert by a director named Jordan
McClure who wanted me to improv I hate
improv I hate it I hate it I hate it I'm
old school I need
lines which guess means I'm not a very
good actor but Jordan forced me to
improv and I hated it but it took me to
school and by the end of the shoot I was
completely into the character and it
made me comfortable with it so both of
those were very very difficult things
for me to learn to do to do some improv
and to be still in the frame but both of
them the results were very good and the
reviews for both of them have been
better than anything else I've ever done
since we met with you last year you had
a chance to work with Jim Carrey did you
ever think this would happen uh no uh
the one of The Producers at Funny or Die
had directed a film that I was in and uh
got a call asking if I would come and do
it in the morning and I did and there's
Jim Carrey walking around sticking out
his hand like he's an unknown actor
saying hi I'm Jim and inwardly you're
thinking I know but it was really very
very nice and this is something that I
find with um higher level actors most of
them are very kind and they will present
thems that way you know Tom Cruz or hi
I'm Tom giving you the opportunity to
say hi I'm Karen so that you meet on an
equal
level I think it's wonderful so when you
got the call about this short film that
you were doing this comedy thing with
the
heha were you aware that Jim Carrey was
part of it or you you didn't know until
you got on set I I was but the um I did
it as a favor for the producer who
called me because it's not my usual cup
of tea you you know I'm not a comedian I
don't do comedy and um and and it's not
what something that I usually do or
something I would have done had not you
know a favor been called in and I'm glad
I did it it was a great experience it
was it was an anomaly for me but that's
this sound if you owe someone a favor
and they store up that favor and because
they had used me for some shoots before
and I did owe the favor and if someone
calls in that favor and says hey Karen
spill you know I'm going to have to do
whatever this is unless it's you know
killing a child or something because the
worst thing in this business is to be
known as yeah I did her a favor and I
asked her for one she wouldn't do it
word gets
around so yeah repay your favors since
you shot the film and it's aired on
funni or die and I think it's it's all
over other YouTube and things like that
have you noticed an impact uh yes my mom
called and said I saw you on Fox
News what's going on
so um
it I don't usually get involved in
anything that makes any sort of
political statement so my hometown
newspaper of course you know they want
to do an interview so you know I said it
was an acting job and it was fun to do
and I'm glad to have had it but it
doesn't you know necessarily represent
any of my own personal political views I
think it's had something like um three
four million hits something like that
take this
lollipop has had over 110 million hits
so far and Counting so more people have
seen me stalking them on Facebook than
have seen me being the host of
heha how did that feel to have sort of
the local boy makes good um aspect uh
very weird very weird because you know
how it is when people in your hometown
they'll be like I knew Karen I knew her
and she was growing up who does she
think she is you're always very aware of
that so you always want to downplay
everything so hey local Pap calling you
just want to an Oscar oh yeah you know I
mean it's I needed a door stop and so
I'll just you know put it there so it's
not a big deal you never want to be the
one that says all yes I knew I would do
it I hate that I hate it always knew
this was going to happen yeah yeah
what's more important for an actor Bill
their resume or their IMDb page IMDb is
your
resume okay it's it's everything um IMDb
is where people go to see whether you've
been working who you've worked with if
you don't have a lot of credits on your
IMBD page and some of them are not in
red showing that they're in
pre-production or filming or just in
post then you're not considered to be
working it doesn't matter what your
resumé says because people don't have
time anymore to do anything other than
give you a 20 second Google and the
first thing is going to come up as your
IMBD so I'm a big believer in pimping
out your IMBD page put your tweets on
there put your blog post on there there
try to get comments on there you want it
to look full and Rich
because I I may be wrong but I think
that's an actor's web page today that is
our website what about your bio how long
do you make it there's some people that
I mean they have a disertation written
and then there's others as just a quick
thing what do you think is the best
approach to writing your bio on IMDb
here's my little IMDb bio trick when you
Google yourself look in the first
sentence and a half roughly of your IMBD
bio show in the extract on the Google
page so that first sentence and a half
is crucial because many times people
won't even click to the IMBD they're
just seeing who you are and that bio
should tell exactly who you are don't
waste that first sentence and a half
with he was born in Kansas and he likes
puppies nobody cares nobody cares so
when I started out my bio said bber Jr
is an American actor known for
disturbing on screen presence I wasn't I
am now but I wasn't but I said I was was
and it became true it's very very
important now I've switched it to Bill
Jr's the face of the Emy
awardwinning application from Jason Zada
take this lollipop and then the rest so
that way even if they never go deeper
into the bio they get that extract on
the Google page so if someone doesn't
have the experience they would like
should they write something that's
almost a self-fulfilling prophecy yes
self-fulfilling prophecy you are so
right that's very very smart of you to
say that perception is reality my
manager Matt Chason says this to me all
the time perception is reality in this
business and it's not a joke it's true
what you want to be known for say that
you already are known for it and it
helps people categorize you because it's
really important in LA to have casting
directors know what you're known for and
it helps them do their job what if you
don't know your category what if you
don't know how to identify yourself what
what if you're still in a work in
progress if you don't know how to
identify yourself then you don't know
your brand and if you don't know your
brand you won't work create a brand the
best way to do it if you don't know how
to do it yourself you can pay people
thousands and thousands of dollars to do
this or you can work if you're just
starting out take the jobs whether they
pay or not and talk to the DP and the
director they're the ones looking at the
lens sometime you'll do a thing on
camera and you'll hear a DP say wow this
really good what was that thing what did
I do something with my eyes something
with my face what was it what was it
question them what is it not what makes
me look good in the frame because that's
just vanity what does the camera love to
see me do how can I make love to the
camera how can I kiss the camera you
find that thing everybody has that thing
if you're not looking for it then you're
either not working not talking to the
DPS or you just lazy my experience is
nobody cares if you're versatile because
everybody's versatile if you can do
everything you can do nothing pick those
few things that you can do extremely
well on camera to the exclusion of
everyone else and promote the hell out
of so don't say you're a chameleon no I
don't think a chameleon works again
perhaps if you're very young and very
beautiful a lot of this goes out of the
window but I am neither I can't be a
chameleon the casting directors have to
say I want that guy that has the fill-in
the blank get me that guy they don't
have time for much else they're very
very busy and you have to help them you
have to be the solution to their
problem you've booked 100 roles in the
last 5
years if someone were to come to you and
ask you how you did it what would you
tell them what's the reader digest
version of how you did
it never turn down a roll when you're
starting because you can't afford to
work work work work
work audition make cold
calls build
relationships Network promote your work
and I I think probably the most
important part of that equation is
promoting your work when you've done
something no matter how small trumpet it
because people in the industry want to
know that you're working you are not
desirable if you're not
working and if you're working and they
don't know you're
working it's the same as not
working so don't be afraid to say I just
did a fantastic short and I had a
supporting role now you don't have to
say I'm fantastic I was great in this
short instead you say I'm really happy
to have worked with Phil in the blank on
what I think was a very artistic
Endeavor the DP blah blah did a
fantastic job I'm glad to have played a
small part in the process even if you
were the lead say that then those people
are then going to repost you and further
help promote but I think you have to
promote your work and that's how you get
more work because people say oh well
Karen's working I want her because other
people want her just like dating take us
to one of your cold calls the moment the
phone picks up
hello U usually it's a producer uh
because nobody deals with
producers and I had a producer early on
tell me you know nobody gives us the
respect we're part of the team too and I
thought aha opportunity so usually I've
written to the producer and ask could I
give you a call this happened after take
this lollipop I contacted uh producers
of German content for German television
because take this lollipop ran on dple
TV and I had a bite and so we set up a
phone conference and it was by Skype and
you know they're in Berlin and I'm here
and they say hello how are you and I
said you know I'm fine how are
you did you get a chance to take a look
at the lollipop go ahead and and
immediately
begin don't waste their time immediately
began and then they'll say yes we did
well that ended up turning into a little
production
deal from that company from a cold call
so but for every one of those that works
you know you go through 79 that don't in
terms of the cold call etiquette how do
you approach it are you long- winded and
friendly and jovial in your approach or
are you very business-minded you have to
be who you are as a person and that'll
come through your naturalness and I'm
not long-winded I'm not jovial and at
parties I just stand in the corner and
want to talk about serious subjects so
that's not who I am so we probably
calling you I'll be like um Karen how
are you and once you say fine I'm done
with the joviality I'm ready to move on
to the business I think you have to be
yourself so you say Hi how are you and I
say fine go to your I'll say great I
wanted to talk to you about blah blah
blah the same with an email um hi Karen
hope you've been well I'm writing
because blah blah I want that second
sentence to tell you why is this because
a lot of times I'll get an email or even
a phone call
and I don't know what they want all I
need to know in the course of my day is
what do you want from me and I don't
mean that in a bad way I just mean let's
begin the dialogue what is it that you
want and if you're not asking for the
sale and making the request and telling
me what you want I can't tell you if I
can help you or not and I go through
three paragraphs of the email and I just
get discouraged and I'll just save it an
archive and say I'm going to look at
this later and then a month later
they'll call and say did you ever look
at so and so and what I want to say
is just tell me what you want so yeah
being being direct really helps with
this business of course that was a
long-winded answer wasn't very direct I
the retrieval now that's a film that
played it South by Southwest this year
correct and you had a leading role in it
what do you love about the film and how
beneficial was it for you to attend the
festival well I'll tell you that this is
an example of taking every job because
there's a job I did three years ago and
it was an audition that I didn't want to
go to to I specifically remember the day
because I thought the part wasn't right
for me and I made myself get up and go I
was really discouraged and depressed
that day about not working but I went we
did the film and I never heard anything
for almost three years and I figured
well you know that was a waste um and it
turned out that the film was finished
and it ended up in South by Southwest so
there I am in Austin attending the
premiere of my first film that's run at
South by Southwest and it won an award
at South by Southwest and has went on to
win awards for director and for cast at
Ashlin independent in Oregon and at the
Phoenix film festival and running as a
part of the SAG foundation's
conversation series for sag members to
come and watch it so um it's turned out
to be very prestigious and a nice
highlevel project for me but it turned
started out as an audition that I didn't
really want to go
to what factored into your decision in
terms of going to South by Southwest how
was that important to your brand I
called my manager and I said um you know
there's a film that I'm a co-lead in
that's running in South by Southwest and
he said you're
going I said well you know I don't
really know if I can work my schedule if
I can afford it this and that and he
said you're going you don't miss an
opportunity like this you're going to
South by Southwest so I went and I'm
really really glad I went um it's just
again it's the perception that people
have they see you at South by Southwest
they see photos of you there it it's
it's important it enhances your status
in the
industry in general would you advise
other filmmakers or actors to make sure
to attend their Festival yeah if you're
in a festival and you don't go you're
missing an opportunity if put it on a
credit card and go um beg a room to stay
with a friend put an ad on Craigslist do
whatever you have to go to be there to
be associated with your film it's a
golden opportunity these film festivals
are um you know you work you work work
so so hard on a film and you've got it
in front of an audience and there's
press there for you not to be there is
it's it's a real big opportunity missed
if you can go in any way go and once you
go what are you bringing with you aside
a great suit maybe or your cards what
are you doing so that you're not that
guy that's you know totally promoting
themselves but at the same time you're
available you're approachable you're
asking other people about their work
everybody that you meet everybody has
work they're doing that they want to
promote everybody has something they
want to tell you don't talk about
yourself talk about
them hi I'm Bill OB Jr that's all you
have to say to somebody in the industry
hi I'm Bob Jones they will tell you then
everything they want you listen you nod
you ask intelligent follow-up questions
and they will say wow he's one of the
best conversationalist I've ever and
that's because you talked about them and
you listened to them everybody wants to
be listened to so never start sentences
with I in other words if you're at the
film festival they don't need to know
what else you've been well yes I just
did this web series and I'm working on
blah blah blah and I went to producers
call back you already had the film
festival you're in the freaking movie
that's running at the film festival now
let it be about them and that makes you
appear even
bigger because if you're with a big star
I don't think that you're ever going to
hear them say you know oh I just
finished this movie with Scorsese they
don't need to say that and so that's the
kind of aura that you want to put off is
that you're about other
people telling all my tricks
here what would you tell a younger actor
seeking an agent before you approach an
agent of about representing you um put
yourself in the agent's shoes and have
empathy for them and understand that if
they say no it's nothing personal this
will also help you understand what the
agent may be looking
for the only reason that an agent is
going to be interested in you is that
they think they can make money off of
you understand that it's not about
whether they like you or not it's
whether you as a commodity can make them
money if it's a good fit and um they'll
be very interested in you if they think
they can make money off of you so when
you make your approach to them why are
you
marketable you know what about you makes
you special or different from any other
actor in your category know those things
and don't be afraid to say them and and
to ask for the sale to to end the
conversation by saying reiterating those
points by saying you know Karen I would
really like to be associated with your
agency because ABC which are the same
things you said at the
beginning it's a business sales call so
this hypothetical young actor is going
to meet for an agent the first time yes
what are they doing the day leading up
two days leading up and then once they
get to the office treated like an
audition um which means you are going to
be early you're going to be well
prepared you are already going to have
had the conversation in your head so
many times that you're absolutely
comfortable you're never flumix you're
going to wear something that you feel
really comfortable in and that morning
you're going to do something that you
really love to do and have plenty of
time to get there that's so important in
La do not ever be rushed cuz it'll show
in your face
and then when you get there listen when
I had my agent meeting for the agent
that I just signed with the she didn't
ask me very many questions mostly I
listen because if you're sitting across
the desk from an agent they've already
done their due diligence they've done
their homework you don't have to impress
them they'll ask you what they want to
know of you what they really want to
know is they want to look into your eyes
and say can I trust you and you trust
me
sounds like that's a really interesting
tip and a very big part of what you do
is getting your mindset in a great place
before you go somewhere understand that
as an actor you're an Entertainer and
your job is to entertain um even if
you're meeting with an agent you want it
to be a pleasant encounter for them you
want them to feel uplifted you want
their day to be brighter even when
you're doing an audition before you
begin the audition you're an Entertainer
I don't mean you sing a dance
but one of the best tips I ever got was
say your name when you come in the room
so I come in the audition room instead
of standing there looking for my ex I
say hey guys I'm Bill obber Jr that's it
it changes the atmosphere of the room it
makes everybody kind of brighten up or
smile a little bit you're always an
Entertainer if you're an actor and your
job is not to or be concerned
about yourself your job is to lift other
people up that's what an Entertainer
does we lift people up and we make their
days bright
an Entertainer is a servant I think
that's a good mentality to have wow
that's great so you're not what if you
have to do your taxes and you know that
you have to be there or just something
that's just painful will you schedule it
for another time just so you could spend
15 minutes listening to music doing
push-ups yes and going to sort of that
happy place because if you don't you'll
be filled with self-pity and self-pity
is anathema to an actor you'll never
book if you be because they'll feel it
they'll smell it you need to be
confident and successful if there's
something unpleasant that you have to do
yeah try and not to do it the day that
you have an audition or you have a
meeting with an agent or any type of
interaction this morning when I got up
before you I talked to you guys I made
myself turn the computer off for an hour
before I came here and it was really
hard because I thought of a lot of
things I could do online I said no I
don't want to get there and I don't want
to be in this busy busy mindset I really
want to be able to relate as a human
being and look in someone's eyes and
talk because that's a part of our job
too as well as staring at that screen
Bill do you view it as your job to
promote the movies that you act in yes
and um I give credit for this great
quote to Carrie nasana who's an acting
coach and an actress and she told me
that when she books a job Carrie says
look I'm a marketing partner for the
life of your movie that really adds
value because I think what it's about is
is an actor yes I hopefully I can do the
job that you hired me to do but what can
I do beyond that to add value to that
how can I not only meet your
expectations but exceed them and I can
do that by being your marketing partner
for that movie forever and ever and ever
that's part of my job too have you seen
that trait from other actors some um
some not so much some think that it's
you know kind of grubbing to get down in
the trenches and do the tweets and write
about the movie and that they just want
to come in and be the actor actress and
um I can't speak for them but for me it
doesn't work I get much more play and I
book more business when I'm a marketing
partner for the movie because what's
good for the movie is good for me is the
way that I see it why do you think
people don't want to do the promotional
part I don't I don't think it's that
they don't want to work I think it's
that they don't see it as a part of
their job or they think that it enhances
their status not to be involved in the
promotion um but at my level of acting
you know I'm not an a-lister and I I
can't
afford not to
be a full partner because what if the
film does something really well you know
this film that just ran it South by
Southwest yes I am going to be your
marketing partner I'm there and anytime
they include me on any of their
publicity I write the director and I say
thank you for including me I know you
didn't have to do that here's what I'm
doing so don't take it as an expectation
that the movie is going to build you up
your job is to build the movie up your
job doesn't in when you step off set in
some senses you know it it only
begins I got 100 credits and so I've got
100 marketing jobs as long as those
things are around big or small it's my
job wherever I can to push them Bill
you've been in La for four years how
many of those years have you spent in
acting class is being on set considered
an acting class
class if it's not then none I've never
been to an acting class in La I just
came here and started working and I
couldn't afford acting classes so I
figured well I'm just going to work and
I'll learn on set by Falling my ass and
making mistakes and asking DPS what can
I do better and asking the gaffer how
can I find my light and asking the
director you know what did I do wrong
and so that's been my
education um it probably took me 20 or
30 projects to really figure figure out
what I was doing wrong and try to start
to do it right if I had the money I
would have gone to classes but instead I
just went to
work it seems like there's so many
people that are very religious about
going to their acting class once twice a
week and and then they go out to for
coffee afterward and it's this big group
sort of communal thing do you think a
lot of that is a nice social outlet but
maybe it's not beneficial well being on
set is my social outlet I'm a hermit
otherwise but I try to do about a movie
a month and um that's my time to be
social and you know hang around craft
services and talk to people but also to
learn about my craft to learn something
from every single role so I guess that's
doing the actual movies is my acting
class which is a little bit dangerous
because what if you're bad and I have
been but uh yeah again it's just
Financial you know I never had the money
to spend on the acting classes so I just
decided Well I'm just going to start
doing movies and learning as I go what
about someone else who comes to LA and
they don't have money for all of the
gurus and the the workshops and all
these different things that are
constantly marketed to yeah I don't I
don't have the money for those things so
what do they do they go on YouTube they
Google videos they work go to work go to
work that's what you're here for go to
work you can't tell me that in Los
Angeles you can't find work you cannot
tell me that somewhere in this city
right now there's not someone who will
ask you to be a part of their project it
may not be paid and if it pays it may
not be much but if you're just starting
out that's what you do go to work don't
Moon about it don't think about it go to
work get your ass on set get in front of
a camera even if you think you're not
ready get in front of a camera CU that
camera will teach you it will be your
teacher and don't watch movies during
the afternoon in your apartment what's
that don't watch movies during the
afternoon in your apartment why watch a
movie when you can be in a movie which
do you learn more from
be in the
movie how important is an actor's real
as a tool to help someone book work your
reel is huge and your re should be quick
and a trend that I've noticed even over
the five years that I've been here is
shorter Clips uh and clips that are
well-labeled and not not just one long
reel but short clips uh Karen speaks
French and blah blah blah um Karen and
romcom blah blah blah you know split
those things up on YouTube in addition
to your physical reel have lots of very
short clips a minute or less that people
can look at also have some longer scenes
but there's a at least in my experience
there are a lot of people who don't want
to sit through an entire scene they
don't want to take that Journey with you
because they're in the middle of their
day they just want to know what you look
like on camera so give them that
opportunity in very short
clips and then of the sort of actor's
tools the real the resume the imdp page
the agent or the manager if someone had
to pick just one as the most crucial
which would it be you can't pick just
one I mean if if it's your IMD page it
has to be pimped out with your reel
because you want your reel on your any
any actor who does not have a demo reel
uploaded IMBD it's a part of the package
if you don't have your demo reel right
there you're crazy that's so I would say
if you can't do anything else have an
IMBD page and a demo reel but you know
that's not even that's not a faal answer
everything you've mentioned is going to
be needed eventually but if you have to
have something to start with get the
IMBD page up get the pictures up and get
your reel
up of the tools available to an actor
the real the IMDb page the resum the
agent or the manager is there one that
stands out as the best that you could
really have without the rest or no the
Internet Movie Database page is the best
tool that an actor has because it's the
most visible one so um you got to pimp
that page out I know actors and
actresses who don't have pictures on
their page very bad you know loaded up
with pictures and not just pictures you
think are pretty but pictures which show
your brand and I have some people who
will do like you know I want to show my
versatilities every picture looks
different I'm not a fan of that I think
you should constantly reinforce what it
is that you do um also on that page you
can put your demo reel up and you should
you you I think you're allowed something
like four or five demo reels put those
Clips up and finally a a trick that I
learned from Danny tryo from looking at
his page there's a section of IMDb which
is called trademarks and that's where
you can list things that the actor or
actress is known for and it's the same
Theory as the bio what would you like to
be known for say that you're known for
it and that if you do all of these
things then when people go to your IMDb
page they will see a complete picture of
who you are as an actor what you do what
your brand is and it makes it very very
easy to consider you to be hired because
you're a complete commodity
there what if you have the IMDb page the
Rio the resume but not the actor and
manager is that only good for a certain
level and then after a point you can't
really progress without the actor
manager yes it's true you do need
management uh be it a manager or an
agent
in in my case I have both but for years
I just had the manager it's been
tremendously helpful to me I think you
need that you need the outside eye of
someone who looks at the overall Spear
of your career um are you going to pay
them yeah you going to pay them I it's
15% of your income you know your your
agent 10 15% of your income but that's
money that you wouldn't have had and I
know actors who said oh you know I don't
want to get a manager because I don't
want to pay the commission but then you
don't get the rols that would bring you
the money to pay the commission anyway
so yes but again that Internet Movie
Database is very very important because
if you approaching someone to be your
representation that's the first thing
they're going to look at do you know how
to Market yourself do you have a clear
idea of who you are as an actor and it
makes their job a lot easier if you do
on the flip side what about the actor
that gets that agent or manager and then
sits by the phone or watches Nicholson
mov movies during the day if you're
sitting by the phone waiting for your
agent to call you should go home
wherever home is because you're not
going to make it I hear this all the
time my agent does nothing for me my
manager does nothing for me I get 98% of
my work on my own and then the deals are
negotiated through my representation I
will send them leads here's someone
who's interested in working with me and
then I don't hear anything for about a
week and then I get a call back saying
we've done the deal here it is what do
you think
my job is to develop the leads and
that's my work I never ever ever look to
my agent or my manager to bring me work
that's not their
job not their job I don't wait for the
phone to ring if it does that's just
gravy but I'm always working myself
again if that's the mindset please don't
come to LA because there's too many
starving people here so again going I
always use real estate as a as a it's
like you're a realtor your hanging your
license with the broker yes great you've
got that locked in now you're looking on
the MLS for homes excellent analogy
that's exactly what it means it just
means that when you're when you are
trying to promote yourself as the
realtor you can say I'm associated with
ABC agency and it just gives you a
little added stature but you still have
to do the work yourself this is work
that actors don't like to do because we
just want to act you know all I'm the
same way I just want to act but that's
the such a small tip of the iceberg such
a small part of my job